the segment that we've come up with out
of thin air for today what's more likely
but thank you ben rothersberger and the
pittsburgh steelers for giving us our
first
item we spent more than a half hour
talking about it last hour
let's kick off what's more likely with
this simple question miles what's more
likely
ben roethlisberger plays for the
steelers or plays for someone else
in 2021 and just so you're aware of the
rules of the game here you may be
tempted to say
no one no one's the middle ground
no it's either plays for the steelers or
plays for someone else what's more
likely
uh i think it's more likely that he
plays for the steelers
i would say that he's going to play for
the steelers or he's probably not going
to play
because i as we were going on in the
last hour i just don't know who exactly
is really going to be interested in him
enough that you're going to bring him in
and say yes you're going to be our
starting quarterback and you're the one
piece that can take us over the top
i don't really know that there are many
teams that would say that unless you are
the steelers
and you already have that built-in
loyalty with somebody like ben
roethlisberger who's been there for over
a decade
won super bowls for you i think that it
makes a lot of sense for them
to try it one more time if they can work
it out
rather than him going somewhere else i i
don't necessarily see him going
somewhere else
as being more likely than him playing
with the steelers
i agree with you completely he's going
to play for the steelers or play for no
one else in large part because we
struggled last hour to come up with a
short list of teams
that would at least stop and think about
the possibility of pursuing
ben roethlisberger now i could say that
we're just going to fully milk this cow
by having another ben rothersberger
question or i could admit that i screwed
up the first question
i will choose to admit that i screwed up
the first question because what it was
supposed to be was what's more likely
ben roethlisberger plays for the
steelers or retires
so let's try it from that angle just in
the interest
of variety and or covering up my screw
up miles what's more likely he plays for
the steelers or retires
i think it's more likely that he plays
for the steelers than he retires
in part because if he does retire then
he technically owes the steelers money
and i don't know about you but i
wouldn't want to owe anybody that much
money i just wouldn't want to owe
anybody that much money if i retire and
you know they could probably work it out
so that he could keep it or whatever
but i don't know about people money if i
retire
let's drill down one more level then and
this is not the revolt the result of
anyone screw up
what's more likely he plays for the
steelers or they cut him
oh man you're going to make me answer
this one again uh
i'm boy i don't think that they want to
cut him
i don't think they want i don't i think
whatever the word is a mutual agreement
whatever the word is
i think right now based on the way kevin
colbert spoke yesterday
i think he's getting everyone ready for
what's coming and what's coming is
we just can't figure our way out of this
maze we've tried we've looked at it
every way we possibly can
we'd love to have him back but given the
salary kept given the pandemic they'll
blame 50 things
other than we're just deciding it's time
to move on i really do think that's
where this is going
they're going to move on and he's going
to move out and he's not going to play
for anyone else
and in five years we start having the
conversation of whether or not he gets
into the hall of fame and he should
all right let's move on what's more
likely dwayne haskins revives his career
in pittsburgh
or he's not on the week one roster
oh it's that he's not on the week one
roster i mean until
he proves that he's matured uh more than
what he
showed um when he was in washington then
i mean i don't know that there's any
other way i can answer the question i
mean he just
the maturity thing was huge there and
you don't necessarily cut a guy that you
pick in the middle of the first round
that's a quarterback
unless you really believe that he has to
go
and i think the only way that really
happens is if there's a maturity issue
so from that perspective he's got a lot
to prove
in pittsburgh and i would say at this
point it's much more likely that he's
just not on that week one roster
i'm gonna disagree with you because i
think that i think he got the wake-up
call
and sometimes you need to get cut to get
the wake-up call early in your career
look at what it did for chris carter
when the eagles cut him now that was
before you were born but i'm sure you
have access to google
but chris carter played for the eagles
and he had substance abuse issues
and that was when buddy ryan coined the
phrase all he does is catch touchdowns
he was covering for chris carter's
substance abuse issues when he cut him
he lands with the vikings via the waiver
system he actually wanted to go to the
giants
and he becomes a hall of famer there so
sometimes you need and i think that's
why teams will give a guy
a second chance a third chance they want
the guy
to have his his epiphany while he's
still employed by the team that
originally invested in him
and washington made the huge investment
the 15th overall pick in the draft
and they tried they just decided they
had enough and i think maybe this
this wake-up call for dwayne haskins
because look if it doesn't work here
where else is it going to work and of
all the teams you could land within the
nfl this is the pittsburgh steelers for
crying out loud
you know maybe he he gets himself in the
right mindset
does the right things coaching staff
works with him and he proves
to them and to himself that he's matured
you know these guys get thrust into pro
football at such an early age and he was
i think younger than most he was like
21-ish
and sometimes it takes a little while
the brain is still developing for anyone
in their early 20s
and i i think it's more likely he
revives his career now that's misleading
because that would assume he had a
career to revive in the first place
but you know we saw flashes we saw
flashes
we had reason to believe that there
could be something there and i think he
could get that back and
when you look at all the depth charts he
could have been on mason rudolph and
josh dobbs he's going to have a chance
to stand out so
we at least we disagree on one it'll be
interesting to see what dwayne haskins
becomes and
you know if they think they have
something in dwayne haskins it makes it
easier to move on without ben
roethlisberger
all right there's a report that the
broncos have not contacted the agents
for
von miller or kareem jackson who have
option payments due this year now again
there's no reason to talk if we don't
know what the caps going to be
but von miller is due to make 18
million dollars in the final year of his
contract he didn't play at all last year
i don't think he's going to be on the
team
what's more likely von miller is on the
team
or desean watson is on the denver
broncos team
what's more likely i love this um
because i don't necessarily think that
von miller is going to be there either
but
i think it's probably more likely that
von miller
and the broncos work something out and
figure out how
they can keep him on that team and you
know von miller doesn't necessarily have
to go anywhere
and he can still be where he's
comfortable i think that's more likely
than desean watson somehow making his
way to denver because
denver trades three first-round picks or
four first-round picks
and drew lock to the texans and they
agree to that
i don't know that denver has the right
ammo
in order to land deshaun watson so i
almost feel like
it's more likely that von miller will be
back because he's got that familiarity
with the team and somehow they can work
it out
i continue to be fascinated though by
what drew luck did
to the texans december of 2019 when the
broncos weren't good they haven't been
good since they won the super bowl and
the texans were
were a playoff team drew locke went in
there and had a great game that was the
buzz lightyear game
your buzz lightyear is not before your
time right you're at least on board with
me with buzz lightyear
he threw the touchdown pass and he's
doing the buzz lightyear stuff and it's
like drew lock this is great personality
who's got the potential to be a
franchise quarterback
he showed that all in houston against
the texans so maybe
maybe the broncos have in addition to
the draft picks a guy that they could
dangle
that could get folks in houston
specifically the two guys who run the
show
cal mcnair and jack easterby who were
there for what happened in 2019
to say hey maybe we'd like this drew
lock guy to be our starting quarterback
if desean watson really doesn't want to
be here so i say it's more likely
desean watson will be on the team i
think von miller
all he has to say is no i'm not redoing
my deal he gets a free ticket to the
open market and he can go
join one of the super teams and try to
pursue another
super bowl ring john robinson the gm of
the titans recently
spoke to reporters and addressed the
issues with the team's
pass rush here's some of what robinson
had to say
we try to put a plan together last last
year with with building a team
and adding some players and um you know
there were some
some players that came on the team in
free agency that
that that bought in and were about what
we're about and there's there's some
that did it didn't work
um for a myriad of reasons um but i
think that that's a position that
um you know we're definitely interested
in and would love to have a guy that
commands double teams and gets gets two
sacks i mean at the end of the day the
the players are the ones that make the
plays
and um we got to try to get as many of
them as possible todavian did some good
things for us uh last year
before before he got deemed with some
disruptive plays you know the
statistical piece might not have
you know gleaned but he was a disruptive
player on the edge for us
john robinson was referring to vic
beasley when he was talking about guys
that just
didn't work out javian clowney was kind
of working out until he got injured and
the story on jadav and clowney is always
the same
his performance doesn't scream out from
the stat sheet
but it does on the film because he is
disruptive he
he f's the play up as sims likes to say
and clowny is the topic of our next
question here what's more likely clowney
has a productive but
injury-shortened year in 2021 or
he gives a team a full 16 or 17
and it's probably going to be 17 game
season
well i i think it's more likely that he
has a productive but injury shortened
year
i think that's kind of been the story on
him for a lot of his career he just he
gets injured
he's able to wreck things i mean he's
one of these game wrecker guys
but he also sometimes just doesn't put
up the numbers and i think sometimes
that's because
you know teams know that they have to
scheme
against him and so they try to take do
his best to take him out but i think he
still
can be a productive kind of guy but
i mean i don't know i don't i especially
if it's a 17 game season i kind of find
it hard to think that he would be
healthy over the course of a 17 game
season because
it's just not necessarily something that
he's been able to do all that much
he had that micro fracture surgery in
his knee early in his
career and you do that when and i don't
want to go too far down the medical path
because when i do
i inevitably make a mistake but i've
been around this long enough to know
that the micro fracture surgery is
intended to address
a situation where there is no cartilage
in one area or
large areas of the knee you use the
micro fracture to
to use and this is where i start getting
off my skis here or over my skis but
they simulate
cartilage growth through scar tissue and
that becomes the cushioning among the
bones
you do that early in your career what do
you got after six seven
eight years what's really going on
inside that knee and this is a guy who's
had a long list of injuries
and and look it happens it happens but
when he's healthy
he's as disruptive as anyone in the nfl
i agree with you
it's more likely he does have a
productive but injury shortened a year
and the question is
how smitten will someone be to cough up
the money
for the chance to do business with and
clowney and he's been kind of bouncing
around one year at a time the past few
years
he's gonna probably have to do a
one-year deal with someone again this
year as he keeps waiting for the big
payday
that he never really got he got it as
the first overall pick in the draft but
that payday isn't what it used
to be he never got the free agency
payday or the second contract
that he may have earned early in his
career um
all right what's more likely in atlanta
matt
ryan and julio jones are a top five
combination under arthur smith or
neither one is on the team
in 20 after after 2021
i think it's that neither one is on the
team after 2021
and unfortunately i think that the thing
is right now we've just talked about
david clowney and the injuries
look i think julio jones we've got to
see if he can be healthy again
over a 16-week season or 17-game season
as you know we were just talking about i
i think
when you looked at what he did this year
it was one of the first years he's ever
had that he didn't get to a thousand
yards and i remember you know
writing about it each week as it would
be like oh is he gonna play is he gonna
play
because if he doesn't he's gonna you
know not be able to reach this 1 000
yard
mark and it's just been something that
he's so consistently done
i don't know how he's going to be able
to do that next year and as i'm saying
as i'm hearing myself
say this like i think of the atlanta
falcons next year after julio jones you
know has a pro bowl year and they're
going to be like
look at all these detractors you know
i'm gonna be like tom brady
on this freezing cold takes video but i
i just i'm not sure
if they're gonna be able to get there
with him this next year and matt ryan
is not getting any younger either he was
gonna be 36 in may
and i think the arthur smith offense
could be good for both of those guys but
i just feel like
it's more likely that but those two guys
are going to be moved on from in the
near future because
they want to have something where they
can build for the next 10 15 years as
opposed to maybe the next three
we talked earlier about how the steelers
are paying for the sins of salary cap
pass they're really paying for it in
atlanta
as they were in that super bowl window
do what you can to keep the team
together do what you can to make matt
ryan happy and then do what you can to
make julio jones happy once matt ryan
got the 30 million a year
and julio was at 15 that's when he
started clamoring for more he finally
got more it has created a cap problem
they're gonna have a cap nightmare with
or without ryan and jones i think they
just decided
let's do it one more time with ryan and
jones because either way we have a mess
here and maybe that's a team that can
attract some of these
one-year free agents and fill out the
roster because here's the other side of
it
once guys start taking these one-year
contracts with teams they're gonna
fill up spots on the depth chart so
uh you know there will be a point where
if you're a guy who wants to play
and you look at the roster of the bucks
of the packers of the chiefs of the
seahawks of the rams of whoever
and you say i'm not sure i'm going to
get on the field and then you look at
the falcons rush and say boy i'm going
to get on the field there
that's going to make some of these
lesser teams who have other key parts
attractive to guys who are available in
free agency alex smith the washington
quarterback for now
recently told the ringer i've got a lot
of room for growth
on the field so what's more likely alex
smith starts
at least eight games in 2021 or is a
backup quarterback for the whole season
i mean i know i can't push but
is kitty start eight games as a backup
quarterback somewhere because i
i could see that happening in some sort
of way i think he can be one of the most
high quality backups in the league and
i'm talking about
guys like nick foles who probably should
be a high quality backup case keenum
another one of those guys
where they the browns have them now
really high quality backup where
you want him on your team if you know
that you might need if something happens
to your quarterback evans forbid
then he's going to be able to at least
get you to a place
where you can consistently still win
games at a decent baseline
but if you're competing for a
championship
you alex smith i don't think is the guy
that you want as your quarterback he's
37 years old he's obviously coming off a
devastating leg injury and
you know lord knows he should have been
the comeback player of the year i'm very
glad that he was
however if you're really counting on
alex smith to be a starting quarterback
i don't think you're in a position where
you can say yes we are going to be a
championship team
maybe you want him as a bridge guide i
don't know
but i i just i think he should be
probably at this point in his career
very high quality backup i still want to
know who voted for ben roethlisberger
instead of alex smith for the comeback
player of the year award it was 49 for
smith and one for ben
and i don't think the name ever came out
it should because that person
deserves to be properly ridiculed i i've
been struggling with the alex smith
thing and
and and i've i've mentioned previously
that when i
when i see him play i feel like i did
when i used to see my kid play where i'm
just constantly worried
that he's going to get hurt because of
the experience with the broken leg from
a few years ago it dawned on me though
recently when i was talking about
thinking about
trying to understand why the bears would
want carson wentz
they don't have many other options but
alex smith would make sense
because of the matt nagy connection back
to kansas city
alex smith knows that offense he's been
around so long he knows every offense
but he thrived
in kansas city and i think given now
they got to a ceiling with alex smith
that they knew they weren't going to
bust through and then they found patrick
mahomes and they busted through it
but the bears are so far below the
ceiling the chiefs were
at if you're talking about finding a way
to keep guys gainfully employed while
they continue to plot the long-term
answer at quarterback
alex smith makes a lot of sense to me he
makes more sense than nick foles
he makes more sense than carson wentz
because he's going to cost a lot less
than once and you're not going to have
to trade for him
i think washington is going to cut smith
he's got a big salary
non-guaranteed i think that he makes a
ton of sense
for the chicago bears it's one of those
where you think about it you think about
it then all of a sudden it's like i
should have realized this from the
get-go alex smith to the bears
and if he does i say he's going to start
at least eight games in 2021.
yeah that makes sense and i think from
that perspective where it's the bears i
think he does make a lot more sense for
them than a carson wentz where it's more
where carson wins his reclamation
project
alex smith you just know he knows that
offense he knows matt nagy he's gonna
come in there
but also i mean i think about alex smith
and the fact that kansas city had to
bust through that ceiling
there was a year alex smith and i think
matt nagy was still there in
kansas city where he didn't throw a
touchdown pass to a wide receiver and
some of that was kansas city's personnel
and since then they've gotten a lot
better
at the wide receiver position but i just
i i don't think
that that would make chicago a real
contender but i think
it would probably keep people gainfully
employed
and if you're chicago and you're matinee
then that is something that you
definitely have to think about because
the bears were considering moving on
from that that
the the front office and that you know
the whole football operation at that
point
went through at the end of the season so
yeah i think that it would make sense
from that perspective for the bears
yeah i think everybody's on notice and
the bears fans are upset and they need
something to make them feel better about
the team alex smith brings
a cachet in a weird sort of way where
there's so much respect for him and he's
a beloved figure in the nfl
so you bring him to your team it's not
like anybody's gonna boo
alex smith it's not like anybody is
gonna complain
that they got alex smith now yeah look
there's always gonna be that that fringe
of the fan base that'll complain about
everything
but i i just think that alex smith makes
a ton
of sense for the bears and if that's
where he goes then i'll take eight games
all right this last one is a very
important topic
carefully crafted by our producer matt
casey tim tebow announced last night his
retirement from
baseball after a five-year quest to make
it to the show
with the new york mets so what's more
likely now that tim tebow has retired
from baseball
and has suggested that there are other
things he wants to do with his time
these are a couple of
football possibilities what's more
likely tim tebow
joins urban meyer's staff as the
director of sports performance
that's a position that became available
last friday or
he's hired by jack easterby
as a special adviser to the houston
texans what's more likely uh i
see i don't necessarily know what tim
tebow's strength and conditioning
regimens are
and i'm sure that urban meyer still
loves them but i'm going to go with jack
he's huge he's huge i don't care what
his methods are they work
you don't know but it doesn't
necessarily mean it's going to work for
everybody i don't know you're going to
hire alex guerrero for everybody
although maybe you should i don't know
yes i want to hire alex guerrero
i do too really and i'm still young uh i
wouldn't know i'm going with jack
eastwood
and the houston texans they've got the
patriots connection from 2013
that was the one year that tim tebow oh
well done well done goodbye that was his
first year as their character coach back
then so uh that's that's where i'm going
they've already got the connections
and and look at this point the texans
need anything that they can get
to rebuild the reputation of the team is
completely and totally dysfunctional the
reality though is plenty of us who
already regard the texans as
dysfunctional
would regard them as even more
dysfunctional if they carve out some job
for the latest of jack easterby's
buddies to come work for the team
i'm fascinated by the possibility he's
going to end up with urban meyer in some
capacity who knows
maybe as a backup quarterback you never
know you never know
look there's still this sense he was
wrongfully deprived of his nfl career
he's only 33. he's 10 years younger than
tom brady for crying out loud put the
guy back on the field
i want excitement that would be exciting
to see
tebow back in uniform i'm being told to
shut up about the possibility of tebow
back on a football field it could be
worse he could be playing for the jets
man casey let's take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports